I'm standing outside the Bank Of New Zealand
at Cenotaph Corner in Rangiora.
We're looking at an initiative of the Rangiora
Community Board, now the Rangiora-Ashley Community
Board to beautify the town centre as a result
of the earthquakes and the street upgrades
that have gone on.
One of my favourite pictures here is of the
market day in 1910.
What appeals to me about that, is all the
gigs stacked up and for those of you that
understand farming in those days, the farmers
would go off to the market, have a successful
sale, have a few noggins and my mind just
boggles as they try to untangle the web of
gigs at the end of the day.
This is another picture that I find really
interesting.
This is the Junction Hotel, nattily known
as Robbie’s.
It was originally damaged in the 1922 earthquakes
and it lost the upper part of the parapet.
It was further damaged in the 2010-2011 earthquakes,
but it has been saved, the front has been
saved and the rest of the building demolished,
so it's an important part of the Rangiora
history.
This picture is of Worth elephants in 1951,
taken as they were parading down the High
Street on their way to Dudley Park.
What I think's important about this picture,
is it's something we'll never ever see in
Rangiora again as circus animals are really
a thing of the past.
I hope you found these pictures interesting;
they depict much of the history of Rangiora.
If you'd like to see more of them, they can
be seen at the Rangiora Museum in Good Street.